as we've lived through the pandemic  perhaps you've tried to find different  ways to eat healthy and  keep off the pandemic pounds well now  sales of so-called  halo superfoods are bringing a fortune  to farmers  things like ginger are selling so fast  farm workers can hardly keep up  scientists have long dismissed many of  the claims about superfoods fending off  viruses however  they all agree it's good for your diet  before  i take it but it's not much but due to  the  v19 we take it now every time  in my house in the morning when we are  drinking we take ginger  prices for superfoods like acai berries  from brazil  indian turmeric and chinese garlic have  also spiked in the last year